The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
MITOpenCourseWare@ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, folks.
Welcome back.
Hope you had a nice long
weekend with no classes.
You got caught up on all
those problem sets that
have been sneaking up on you.
You enjoyed watching
the Patriots and Tom
Brady come back.
Oh, sorry, I'm
showing my local bias.
Before we talk
about today's topic,
I want to take a second
to set the stage.
And I want you to stop and
think about what you've
seen so far in this course.
We're coming up on the
end of the first section
of the course.
And you've already seen a lot.
You've certainly learned about
fundamentals of computation.
You've seen different
kinds of data structures,
both mutable and immutable, so
tuples and lists, dictionaries,
different ways of
pulling things together.
You've seen a
range of algorithms
from simple linear code
to loops, fors and whiles.
You've seen
iterative algorithms.
recursive algorithms.
You've seen classes
of algorithms.
Divide and conquer.
Greedy algorithms.
Bisection search.
A range of things.
And then most recently,
you start pulling things
together with classes--
a way to group together
data that belongs together along
with methods or procedures that
are designed to
manipulate that data.
So you've had actually
a fairly good coverage
already of a lot of the
fundamentals of computation.
And you're starting
to get geared up
to be able to tackle a pretty
interesting range of problems.
Today and Monday,
we're going to take
a little bit of a different
look at computation.
Because now that you've got
the tools to start building up
your own personal
armamentarium of tools,
we'd like to ask a couple
of important questions.
The primary one of which is how
efficient are my algorithms?
And by efficiency, we'll see it
refers both to space and time,
but primarily to time.
And we'd like to know both how
fast are my algorithms going
to run and how could I reason
about past performance.
And that's what we're going
to do with today's topics.
We're going to talk
about orders of growth.
We'll define what that
means in a few minutes.
We're going to talk about what's
called the big O notation.
And we're going to begin to
explore different classes
of algorithms.
Before we do that though,
let's talk about why.
And I want to suggest to you
there are two reasons this
is important to be considering.
First question is how could
we reason about an algorithm
something you write in order
to predict how much time is
it going to need to solve a
problem of a particular size?
I might be testing my code
on small scale examples.
And I want to know if I'd run
it on a really big one, how
long is it going to take?
Can I predict that?
Can I make guesses
about how much time
I'm going to need to
solve this problem?
Especially if it's
in a real world
circumstance where time
is going to be crucial.
Equally important is
going the other direction.
We want you to begin to
reason about the algorithms
you write to be
able to say how do
certain choices in a design
of an algorithm influence
how much time it's
going to take.
If I choose to do
this recursively,
is that going to be
different than iteratively?
If I choose to do this with a
particular kind of structure
in my algorithm, what does
that say about the amount
of time I'm going to need?
And you're going to see
there's a nice association
between classes of algorithms
and the interior structure
of them.
And in particular, we want to
ask some fundamental questions.
Are there fundamental
limits to how much time
it's going to take to
solve a particular problem,
no matter what kind of
algorithm I design around this?
And we'll see that there
are some nice challenges
about that.
So that's what we're going
to do over the next two days.
Before we do though, let's
maybe ask the obvious question--
why should we care?
Could be on a quiz,
might matter to you.
Better choice is because it
actually makes a difference.
And I say that because it
may not be as obvious to you
as it was in an
earlier generation.
So people with my gray hair
or what's left of my gray hair
like to tell stories.
I'll make it short.
But I started programming
41 years ago-- no,
sorry, 45 years
ago-- on punch cards.
You don't know what those are
unless you've been to a museum
on a machine that
filled a half a room
and that took about
five minutes to execute
what you can do in a fraction
of a second on your phone.
Right.
This is to tell you're
living in a great time, not
independent of what's going
to happen on November 8th.
All right.
We'll stay away from those
topics as well, won't we?
My point is yeah,
I tell old stories.
I'm an old guy.
But you might argue
look, computers
are getting so much faster.
Does it really matter?
And I want to say to you--
maybe it's obvious to you--
yes, absolutely it does.
Because in conjunction with
us getting faster computers,
we're increasing the
sizes of the problems.
The data sets we want to
analyze are getting massive.
And I'll give you an example.
I just pulled this off
of Google, of course.
In 2014-- I don't have
more recent numbers--
Google served-- I think I
have that number right--
30 trillion pages on the web.
It's either 30 trillionaire
or 30 quadrillion.
I can't count that
many zeros there.
It covered 100 million
gigabytes of data.
And I suggest to you if you want
to find a piece of information
on the web, can you write a
simple little search algorithm
that's going to sequentially
go through all the pages
and find anything in any
reasonable amount of time?
Probably not.
Right?
It's just growing way too fast.
This, by the way, is of course,
why Google makes a lot of money
off of their map
reduced algorithm
for searching the web,
written by the way,
or co-written by an MIT grad
and the parent of a current MIT
student.
So there's a nice
hook in there, not
that Google pays MIT royalties
for that wonderful thing,
by the way.
All right.
Bad jokes aside, searching
Google-- ton of time.
Searching a genomics
data set-- ton of time.
The data sets are
growing so fast.
You're working for
the US government.
You want to track terrorists
using image surveillance
from around the world,
growing incredibly rapidly.
Pick a problem.
The data sets grow
so quickly that even
if the computers
speed up, you still
need to think about how to
come up with efficient ways
to solve those problems.
So I want to suggest
to you while sometimes
simple solutions are great,
they are the easy ones to rate--
too write.
Sorry.
At times, you need to
be more sophisticated.
Therefore, we want
to reason about
how do we measure
efficiency and how do we
relate algorithm design
choices to the cost that's
going to be associated with it?
OK.
Even when we do that,
we've got a choice to make.
Because we could talk about
both efficiency in terms of time
or in terms of space,
meaning how much storage
do I have inside the computer?
And the reason
that's relevant is
there's actually in many cases
a trade-off between those two.
And you've actually seen an
example, which you may or may
not remember.
You may recall when we
introduced dictionaries,
I showed you a
variation where you
could compute Fibonacci
using the dictionary to keep
track of intermediate values.
And we'll see in next week
that it actually tremendously
reduces the time complexity.
That's called a trade-off,
in the sense that sometimes I
can pre-compute
portions of the answer,
store them away,
so that when I've
tried to a bigger
version of the answer
I can just look
up those portions.
So there's going to
be a trade-off here.
We're going to
focus, for purposes
of this lecture and the next
one, on time efficiency.
How much time is it going
to take our algorithms
to solve a problem?
OK.
What are the challenges
in doing that before we
look at the actual tools?
And in fact, this is going
to lead into the tools.
The first one is even if
I've decided on an algorithm,
there are lots of ways
to implement that.
A while loop and a for loop
might have slightly different
behavior.
I could choose to do it
with temporary variables
or using direct substitution.
There's lots of little choices.
So an algorithm
could be implemented
many different ways.
How do I measure the actual
efficiency of the algorithm?
Second one is I might,
for a given problem,
have different
choices of algorithm.
A recursive solution
versus an iterative one.
Using divide and conquer
versus straightforward search.
We're going to see
some examples of that.
So I've got to somehow
separate those pieces out.
And in particular, I'd
like to separate out
the choice of implementation
from the choice of algorithm.
I want to measure how
hard is the algorithm,
not can I come up
with a slightly more
efficient way of coming
up with an implementation.
So here are three
ways I might do it.
And we're going to look at
each one of them very briefly.
The obvious one is we could
be scientists-- time it.
Write the code, run a bunch
of test case, run a timer,
use that to try and come up with
a way of estimating efficiency.
We'll see some
challenges with that.
Slightly more abstractly,
we could count operations.
We could say here are the set
of fundamental operations--
mathematical operations,
comparisons, setting values,
retrieving values.
And simply say how many
of those operations
do I use in my
algorithm as a function
of the size of the input?
And that could be used to
give us a sense of efficiency.
We're going to see both of
those are flawed somewhat more
in the first case
than the second one.
And so we're going to
abstract that second one
to a more abstract
notion of something
we call an order of growth.
And I'll come back to that
in a couple of minutes.
This is the one we're
going to focus on.
It's one that computer
scientists use.
It leads to what we
call complexity classes.
So order of growth
or big O notation
is a way of
abstractly describing
the behavior of an
algorithm, and especially
the equivalences of
different algorithms.
But let's look at those.
Timing.
Python provides a timer for you.
You could import
the time module.
And then you can call, as
you can see right down here.
I might have defined a really
simple little function--
convert Celsius to Fahrenheit.
And in particular, I could
invoke the clock method
from the time module.
And what that does
is it gives me
a number as the number of some
fractions of a second currently
there.
Having done that I
could call the function.
And then I could call the clock
again, and take the difference
to tell me how much time
it took to execute this.
It's going to be a
tiny amount of time.
And then I could certainly
print out some statistics.
I could do that
over a large number
of runs-- different
sizes of the input--
and come up with a sense of
how much time does it take.
Here's the problem with that.
Not a bad idea.
But again, my goal is
to evaluate algorithms.
Do different algorithms
have different amounts
of time associated with them?
The good news is is that
if I measure running time,
it will certainly vary
as the algorithm changes.
Just what I want to measure.
Sorry.
But one of the problems
is that it will also
vary as a function of
the implementation.
Right?
If I use a loop that's got a
couple of more steps inside
of it in one algorithm
than another,
it's going to change the time.
And I don't really care
about that difference.
So I'm confounding or conflating
implementation influence
on time with algorithm
influence on time.
Not so good.
Worse, timing will
depend on the computer.
My Mac here is pretty old.
Well, at least for
computer versions.
It's about five years old.
I'm sure some of you have
much more recent Macs
or other kinds of machines.
Your speeds may be
different from mine.
That's not going to help me
in trying to measure this.
And even if I could measure
it on small sized problems,
it doesn't necessarily
predict what
happens when I go to a
really large sized problems,
because of issues
like the time it
takes to get things
out of memory
and bring them back
in to the computer.
So what it says is
that timing does
vary based on what
I'd like to measure,
but it varies on a
lot of other factors.
And it's really not
all that valuable.
OK.
Got rid of the first one.
Let's abstract that.
By abstract, I'm going to
make the following assumption.
I'm going to identify a set
of primitive operations.
Kind of get to
say what they are,
but the obvious
one is to say what
does the machine do
for me automatically.
That would be things
like arithmetic
or mathematical operations,
multiplication, division,
subtraction,
comparisons, something
equal to another thing,
something greater than,
something less
than, assignments,
set a name to a value,
and retrieval from memory.
I'm going to assume that
all of these operations
take about the same amount
of time inside my machine.
Nice thing here
is then it doesn't
matter which machine I'm using.
I'm measuring how long
does the algorithm take
by counting how many
operations of this type
are done inside
of the algorithm.
And I'm going to use
that count to come up
with a number of
operations executed
as a function of the
size of the input.
And if I'm lucky,
that'll give me
a sense of what's the
efficiency of the algorithm.
So this one's pretty boring.
It's got three steps.
Right?
A multiplication, a division,
and an addition-- four,
if you count the return.
But if I had a little
thing here that added up
the integers from
0 up to x, I've
got a little loop inside here.
And I could count operations.
So in this case, it's just,
as I said, three operations.
Here, I've got one operation.
I'm doing an assignment.
And then inside
here, in essence,
there's one operation to set i
to a value from that iterator.
Initially, it's going to be 0.
And then it's going to be 1.
And you get the idea.
And here, that's
actually two operations.
It's nice Python shorthand.
But what is that operation?
It says take the value of
total and the value of i,
add them together--
it's one operation--
and then set that value,
or rather, set the name
total to that new value.
So a second operation.
So you can see in here,
I've got three operations.
And what else do I have?
Well, I'm going to go
through this loop x times.
Right?
I do it for i equals 0.
And therefore, i
equal 1, and so on.
So I'm going to run
through that loop x times.
And if I put that together, I
get a nice little expression.
1 plus 3x.
Actually, I probably
cheated here.
I shouldn't say cheated.
I probably should have
counted the return
as one more operation, so that
would be 1 plus 3x plus 1,
or 3x plus 2 operations.
Why should you care?
It's a little closer
to what I'd like.
Because now I've
got an expression
that tells me something
about how much time
is this going to take as I
change the size of the problem.
If x is equal to 10, it's
going to take me 32 operations.
If x is equal to
100, 302 operations.
If x is equal to 1,000,
3,002 operations.
And if I wanted the
actual time, I'd
just multiply that by whatever
that constant amount of time
is for each operation.
I've got a good
estimate of that.
Sounds pretty good.
Not quite what we
want, but it's close.
So if I was counting operations,
what could I say about it?
First of all, it certainly
depends on the algorithm.
That's great.
Number of operations is
going to directly relate
to the algorithm I'm
trying to measure,
which is what I'm after.
Unfortunately, it still
depends a little bit
on the implementation.
Let me show you
what I mean by that
by backing up for a second.
Suppose I were to change this
for loop to a while loop.
I'll set i equal to 0
outside of the loop.
And then while i is
less than x plus 1,
I'll do the things
inside of that.
That would actually
add one more operation
inside the loop, because I
both have to set the value of i
and I have to test
the value of i,
as well as doing the other
operations down here.
And so rather than getting 3x
plus 1, I would get 4x plus 1.
Eh.
As the government says,
what's the difference
between three and for
when you're talking
about really big numbers?
Problem is in terms of
counting, it does depend.
And I want to get rid
of that in a second,
so it still depends a little
bit on the implementation.
I remind you, I
wanted to measure
impact of the algorithm.
But the other good
news is the count
is independent of which
computer I run on.
As long as all my computers
come with the same set
of basic operations,
I don't care
what the time of my
computer is versus yours
to do those operations
on measuring
how much time it would take.
And I should say,
by the way, one
of the reasons I want
to do it is last to know
is it going to take 37.42
femtoseconds or not,
but rather to say if
this algorithm has
a particular behavior, if I
double the size of the input,
does that double the
amount of time I need?
Does that quadruple the
Does it increase it
by a factor of 10?
And here, what matters isn't
the speed of the computer.
It's the number of operations.
The last one I'm not going
to really worry about.
But we'd have to
really think about what
are the operations
we want to count.
I made an assumption
that the amount
of time it takes to retrieve
something from memory
is the same as
the amount of time
it takes to do a
numerical computation.
That may not be accurate.
But this one could
probably be dealt
with by just agreeing on what
are the common operations
and then doing the measurement.
So this is closer.
Excuse me.
And certainly, that count
varies for different inputs.
And we can use it to come
up with a relationship
between the inputs
and the count.
And for the most part, it
reflects the algorithm, not
the implementation.
But it's still got that
last piece left there,
so I need to get rid
of the last piece.
So what can we say here?
Timing and counting do evaluate
or reflect implementations?
I don't want that.
Timing also evaluates
the machines.
What I want to do is just
evaluate the algorithm.
And especially, I want to
understand how does it scale?
I'm going to say what I said
a few minutes ago again.
If I were to take
an algorithm, and I
say I know what its
complexity is, my question is
if I double the
size of the input,
what does that say to the speed?
Because that's going to tell me
something about the algorithm.
I want to say what
happens when I scale it?
And in particular, I
want to relate that
to the size of the input.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to introduce
orders of growth.
It's a wonderful tool
in computer science.
And what we're going to
focus on is that idea
of counting operations.
But we're not going to worry
about small variations,
whether it's three or four
steps inside of the loop.
We're going to show that
that doesn't matter.
And if you think about my
statement of does it double
in terms of size or speed
or not-- or I'm sorry-- time
or not, whether it goes from
three to six or four to eight,
it's still a doubling.
So I don't care about
those pieces inside.
I'm going to focus
on what happens
when the size of the problem
gets arbitrarily large.
I don't care about
counting things from 0
up to x when x is 10 or 20.
What happens when
it's a million?
100 million?
What's the asymptotic
behavior of this?
And I want to relate
that time needed
against the size of the
input, so I can make
that comparison I suggested.
OK.
So to do that, we've got
to do a couple of things.
We have to decide what
are we going to measure?
And then we have to
think about how do we
count without worrying about
implementation details.
So we're going to
express efficiency
in terms of size of input.
And usually, this is
going to be obvious.
If I've got a procedure that
takes one argument that's
an integer, the
size of the integer
is the thing I'm going
to measure things in.
If I double the size
of that integer,
what happens to the computation?
If I'm computing
something over a list,
typically the length
of the list is
going to be the thing I'm
going to use to characterize
the size of the problem.
If I've got-- and we'll see this
in a second-- a function that
takes more than
one argument, I get
to decide what's the
parameter I want to use.
If I'm searching to see is
this element in that list,
typically, I'm going
to worry about what's
the size of the list, not
what's the size of the element.
But we have to specify what
is that we're measuring.
And we're going to see examples
of that in just a second.
OK.
So now, we start thinking
about that sounds great.
Certainly fun computing
something numeric.
Sum of integers from 0 up to x.
It's kind of obvious x is
the size of my problem.
How many steps does it take?
I can count that.
But in some cases, the
amount of time the code takes
is going to depend on the input.
So let's take this little
piece of code here.
And I do hope by now, even
though we flash up code,
you're already beginning to
recognize what does it do.
Not the least of which, by
the clever name that we chose.
But this is obviously
just a little function.
It runs through a loop--
sorry, a for loop that takes i
for each element in
a list L. And it's
checking to see is i equal
to the element I've provided.
And when it is, I'm
going to return true.
If I get all the way through
the loop and I didn't find it,
I'm going to return false.
It's just saying is
e in my input list L?
How many steps is
this going to take?
Well, we can certainly count
the number of steps in the loop.
Right?
We've got a set i.
We've got to compare i
and potentially we've
got to return.
So there's at most three
steps inside the loop.
But depends on how
lucky I'm feeling.
Right?
If e happens to be the
first element in the list--
it goes through the
loop once-- I'm done.
Great.
I'm not always that lucky.
If e is not in the
list, then it will
go through this
entire loop until it
gets all the way through
the elements of L
before saying false.
So this-- sort of a
best case scenario.
This is the worst case scenario.
Again, if I'm assigned and say
well, let's run some trials.
Let's do a bunch of examples
and see how many steps
does it go through.
And that would be
the average case.
On average, I'm likely to
look at half the elements
in the list before I find it.
Right?
If I'm lucky, it's early on.
If I'm not so lucky,
it's later on.
Which one do I use?
Well, we're going to
focus on this one.
Because that gives you an upper
bound on the amount of time
it's going to take.
What happens in the
worst case scenario?
We will find at times
it's valuable to look
at the average case to give
us a rough sense of what's
going to happen on average.
But usually, when we
talk about complexity,
we're going to focus on
the worst case behavior.
So to say it in a little
bit different way,
let's go back to my example.
Suppose you gave it a
list L of some length.
Length of L, you can call
that len if you like.
Then my best case would be
the minimum running type.
And in this case, it will be for
the first element in the list.
And notice in that case,
the number of steps I take
would be independent of the
length of L. That's great.
It doesn't matter
how long the list is.
If I'm always going to find
the first element, I'm done.
The average case
would be the average
over the number of
steps I take, depending
on the length of the list.
It's going to grow linearly
with the length of the list.
It's a good practical measure.
But the one I want to focus
on will be the worst case.
And here, the amount
of time as we're
going to see in a
couple of slides,
is linear in the
size of the problem.
Meaning if I double the length
of the list in the worst case,
it's going to take
me twice as much time
to find that it's not there.
If I increase the length in
the list by a factor of 10,
in the worst case,
it's going to take me
10 times as much time as
it did in the earlier case
to find out that the
problem's not there.
And that linear relationship
is what I want to capture.
So I'm going to focus on that.
What's the worst case behavior?
And we're about ready to start
talking about orders of growth,
but here then is
what orders of growth
are going to provide for me.
I want to evaluate
efficiency, particularly when
the input is very large.
What happens when I
really scale this up?
I want to express the growth
of the program's runtime
as that input grows.
Not the exact runtime, but
that notion of if I doubled it,
how much longer does it take?
What's the relationship
between increasing
the size of the input
and the increase
in the amount of time
it takes to solve it?
We're going to put an
upper bound on that growth.
And if you haven't
seen this in math,
it basically says I want to
come up with a description that
is at least as big as--
sorry-- as big as or bigger
than the actual amount of
time it's going to take.
And I'm going to not
worry about being precise.
We're going to talk about the
order of rather than exact.
I don't need to know to the
femtosecond how long this
is going to take, or to exactly
one operation how long this
is going to take.
But I want to say things like
this is going to grow linearly.
I double the size of the input,
it doubles the amount of time.
Or this is going to
grow quadratically.
I double the size
of the input, it's
going to take four times
as much time to solve it.
Or if I'm really lucky, this is
going to have constant growth.
No matter how I
change the input,
it's not going to
take any more time.
To do that, we're going
to look at the largest
factors in the runtime.
Which piece of the program
takes the most time?
And so in orders
of growth, we are
going to look for
as tight as possible
an upper bound on the growth
as a function of the size
of the input in the worst case.
Nice long definition.
Almost ready to look
at some examples.
So here's the notation
we're going to use.
It's called Big O notation.
I have to admit-- and
John's not here today
to remind me the history--
I think it comes because we
used Omicron-- God knows why.
Sounds like something
from Futurama.
But we used Omicron as
our symbol to define this.
I'm having such good luck
with bad jokes today.
You're not even wincing when
I throw those things out.
But that's OK.
It's called Big O notation.
We're going to use it.
We're going to describe
the rules of it.
Is this the tradition of it?
It describes the worst
case, because it's often
the bottleneck we're after.
And as we said, it's
going to express
the growth of the program
relative to the input size.
OK.
Let's see how we go
from counting operations
to getting to orders of growth.
Then we're going to define some
examples of ordered growth.
And we're going to start
looking at algorithms.
Here's a piece of code
you've seen before.
Again, hopefully, you
recognize or can see
fairly quickly what it's doing.
Computing factorials
the iterative way.
Basically, remember
n factorial is
n times n minus 1 times n
minus 2 all the way down to 1.
Hopefully, assuming n is
a non-negative integer.
Here, we're going to set up
an internal variable called
answer.
And then we're just
going to run over a loop.
As long as n is
bigger than 1, we're
going to multiply answer by
n, store it back into answer,
decrease n by 1.
We'll keep doing that until
we get out of the loop.
And we're going
to return answer.
We'll start by counting steps.
And that's, by the way, just to
remind you that in fact, there
are two steps here.
So what do I have?
I've got one step up there.
Set answer to one.
I'm setting up n-- sorry,
I'm not setting up n.
I'm going to test n.
And then I'm going
to do two steps here,
because I got a multiply answer
by n and then set it to answer.
And now similarly, we've
got two steps there
because I'm subtracting 1 from
n and then setting it to n.
So I've got 2 plus 4 plus
the test, which is 5.
I've got 1 outside here.
I got 1 outside there.
And I'm going to go
through this loop n times.
So I would suggest that if
I count the number of steps,
it's 1 plus 5n plus 1.
Sort of what we did before.
5n plus 2 is the total number
of steps that I use here.
But now, I'm interested in
what's the worst case behavior?
Well, in this case, it is
the worst case behavior
because it doesn't have
decisions anywhere in here.
But I just want to know what's
the asymptotic complexity?
And I'm going to
say-- oh, sorry-- that
is to say I could do
this different ways.
I could have done this
with two steps like that.
That would have made it
not just 1 plus 5n plus 1.
It would have made
it 1 plus 6n plus 1
because I've got an extra step.
I put that up because
I want to remind you
I don't care about
implementation differences.
And so I want to
know what captures
both of those behaviors.
And in Big O notation,
I say that's order n.
Grows linearly.
So I'm going to keep
doing this to you
until you really do wince at me.
If I were to double
the size of n,
whether I use this
version or that version,
the amount of time
the number of steps
is basically going to double.
Now you say, wait a minute.
5n plus 2-- if n
is 10 that's 52.
And if n is 20, that's 102.
That's not quite doubling it.
And you're right.
But remember, we
really care about this
in the asymptotic case.
When n gets really big,
those extra little pieces
don't matter.
And so what we're
going to do is we're
going to ignore the
additive constants
and we're going to ignore the
multiplicative constants when
we talk about orders of growth.
So what does o of n measure?
Well, we're just
summarizing here.
We want to describe how much
time is needed to compute
or how does the amount
of time, rather,
needed to computer
problem growth
as the size of the
problem itself grows.
So we want an
expression that counts
that asymptotic behavior.
And we're going to focus as a
consequence on the term that
grows most rapidly.
So here are some examples.
And I know if you're
following along,
you can already see
the answers here.
But we're going to
do this to simply
give you a sense of that.
If I'm counting
operations and I come up
with an expression
that has n squared
plus 2n plus 2 operations,
that expression I say
is order n squared.
The 2 and the 2n don't matter.
And think about what happens
if you make n really big.
n squared is much more
dominant than the other terms.
We say that's order n squared.
Even this expression we
say is order n squared.
So in this case, for
lower values of n,
this term is going to
be the big one in terms
of number of steps.
I have no idea how I wrote
such an inefficient algorithm
that it took 100,000
steps to do something.
But if I had that expression
for smaller values of n,
this matters a lot.
This is a really big number.
But when I'm interested
in the growth,
then that's the
term that dominates.
And you see the idea or
begin to see the idea here
that when I have-- sorry,
let me go back there--
when I have expressions, if
it's a polynomial expression,
it's the highest order term.
It's the term that
captures the complexity.
Both of these are quadratic.
This term is order n, because
n grows faster than log of n.
This funky looking
term, even though that
looks like the big
number there and it
is a big number, that expression
we see is order n log n.
Because again, if
I plot out as how
this changes as I
make n really large,
this term eventually takes
over as the dominant term.
What about that one?
What's the big term there?
How many people think
it's n to the 30th?
Show of hands.
How many people think
it's 3 to the n?
Show of hands.
Thank you.
You're following along.
You're also paying attention.
How many people think I
should stop asking questions?
No show of hands.
All right.
But you're right.
Exponentials are much
worse than powers.
Even something
like this-- again,
it's going to take a big value
of n before it gets there,
but it does get there.
And that, by the
way, is important,
because we're going to
see later on in the term
that there are
some problems where
it's believed that all of the
solutions are exponential.
And that's a pain,
because it says
it's always going to be
expensive to compute.
So that's how we're going to
reason about these things.
And to see it visually,
here are the differences
between those different classes.
Something that's constant--
the amount of time
doesn't change as I change
the size of the input.
Something that linear
grows as a straight line,
as you would expect.
Nice behavior.
Quadratic starts to
grow more quickly.
The log is always
better than linear
because it slows down
as we increase the size.
n log n or log linear
is a funky term,
but we're going to see it's
a very common complexity
for really valuable algorithms
in computer science.
And it has a nice behavior,
sort of between the linear
and the quadratic.
And exponential blows up.
Just to remind you
of that-- well,
sorry-- let me show
you how we're going
to do the reasoning about this.
So here's how we're
going to reason about it.
We've already seen
some code where
I started working through this
process of counting operations.
Here are the tools
I want you to use.
Given a piece of
code, you're going
to reason about each
chunk of code separately.
If you've got sequential
pieces of code,
then the rules are called
the law of addition
for order of growth is
that the order of growth
of the combination
is the combination
of the order of the growth.
Say that quickly 10 times.
But let's look at
an example of that.
Here are two loops.
You've already seen
examples of how
to reason about those loops.
For this one, it's
linear in the size of n.
I'm going to go through the loop
n times doing a constant amount
of things each time around.
But what I just
showed, that's order n.
This one-- again, I'm doing
just a constant number of things
inside the loop-- but
notice, that it's n squared.
So that's order n squared.
n times n.
The combination is I have to do
this work and then that work.
So I write that as saying that
is order of n plus order of n
squared.
But by this up here,
that is the same
as saying what's the order of
growth of n plus n squared.
Oh yeah.
We just saw that.
Says it's n squared.
So addition or the
law of addition
let's be reasonable
about the fact
that this will be an
order n squared algorithm.
Second one I'm going
to use is called
the law of multiplication.
And this says when I have nested
statements or nested loops,
I need to reason about those.
And in that case, what I want
to argue-- or not argue-- state
is that the order of growth
here is a multiplication.
That is, when I
have nested things,
I figure out what's
the order of growth
of the inner part, what's the
order growth of the outer part,
and I'm going to multiply--
bleh, try again-- I'm
going to multiply together
those orders of growth,
get the overall order of growth.
If you think about
it, it makes sense.
Look at my little example here.
It's a trivial little example.
But I'm looping for
i from 0 up to n.
For every value of i, I'm
looping for j from 0 up to n.
And then I'm printing
out A. I'm the Fonz.
I'm saying heyyy a lot.
Oh, come on.
At least throw something,
I mean, when it's that bad.
Right?
Want to make sure
you're still awake.
OK.
You get the idea.
But what I want to show you here
is notice the order of growth.
That's order n.
Right?
I'm doing that n times.
But I'm doing that
for each value of i.
The outer piece here
loops also n times.
For each value of i, I'm
doing order n things.
So I'm doing order of n
times order of n steps.
And by that law, that is
the same order of n times
n or n squared.
So this is a
quadratic expression.
You're going to see that a lot.
Nested loops typically
have that kind of behavior.
Not always, but typically
So what you're going
to see is there's
a set of complexity classes.
And we're about to
start filling these in.
Order one is constant.
Says amount of time it
takes doesn't depend
on the size of the problem.
These are really
rare that you get.
They tend to be trivial pieces
of code, but they're valuable.
Log n reflects
logarithmic runtime.
You can sort of read
the rest of them.
These are the kinds of things
that we're going to deal with.
We are going to see examples
here, here, and here.
And later on, we're going
to come back and see
these, which are really
nice examples to have.
Just to remind you why
these orders of growth
matter-- sorry, that's
just reminding you
what they look like.
We've already done that.
Here is the difference
between constant log,
linear, log linear
squared, and exponential.
When n is equal to 10,
100, 1,000 or a million.
I know you know this, but I want
to drive home the difference.
Something that's constant
is wonderful, no matter
how big the problem is.
Takes the same amount of time.
Something that is
log is pretty nice.
Increase the size of
the problem by 10,
it increases by a factor of 2.
From another 10,
it only increases
by a factor of another 50%.
It only increases a little bit.
That's a gorgeous kind
of problem to have.
Linear-- not so bad.
I go from 10 to 100
to 1,000 to a million.
You can see log linear
is not bad either.
Right?
A factor of 10 increase here
is only a factor of 20 increase
there.
A factor of 10 increase there
is only a factor of 30 increase
there.
So log linear doesn't
grow that badly.
But look at the difference
between n squared and 2
to the n.
I actually did think
of printing this out.
By the way, Python
will compute this.
But it was taken pages
and pages and pages.
I didn't want to do it.
You get the point.
Exponential-- always much worse.
Always much worse than
a quadratic or a power
expression.
And you really see
the difference here.
All right.
The reason I put this up is
as you design algorithms,
your goal is to be as high up
in this listing as you can.
The closer you are to
the top of this list,
the better off you are.
If you have a solution
that's down here,
bring a sleeping
bag and some coffee.
You're going to be
there for a while.
Right?
You really want to try
and avoid that if you can.
So now what we want to do,
both for the rest of today
in the last 15 minutes
and then next week,
is start identifying
common algorithms
and what is their complexity.
As I said to you way
back at the beginning
of this lecture, which
I'm sure you remember,
it's not just to be able
to identify the complexity.
I want you to see
how choices algorithm
design are going to
lead to particular kinds
of consequences in terms of
what this is going to cost you.
That's your goal here.
All right.
We've already seen
some examples.
I'm going to do one more here.
But simple iterative
loop algorithms
are typically linear.
Here's another
version of searching.
Imagine I'll have
an unsorted list.
Arbitrary order.
Here's another way of
doing the linear search.
Looks a little bit faster.
I'm going to set a flag
initially to false.
And then I'm going
to loop for i from 0
up to the length of L.
I'm going to use that
to index into the list, pull
out each element of the list
in turn, and check to see is
it the thing I'm looking for.
As soon as I find it, I'm
going to send-- sorry--
set the flag to true.
OK?
So that when I return out of the
loop, I can just return found.
And if I found it to be
true, if I never found it,
found will still be
false and I'll return it.
We could count the
operations here,
but you've already seen
examples of doing that.
This is linear,
because I'm looping
n times if n is the length
of the list over there.
And the number of things I do
inside the loop is constant.
Now, you might
say, wait a minute.
This is really brain
damaged, or if you're
being more politically correct,
computationally challenged.
OK?
In the sense of
once I've found it,
why bother looking at
the rest of the list?
So in fact, I could just
return true right here.
Does that change the order
of growth of this algorithm?
No.
Changes the average time.
I'm going to stop faster.
But remember the order
of growth captures
what's the worst case behavior.
And the worst case
behavior is the elements
not in the list I got
to look at everything.
So this will be an example
of a linear algorithm.
And you can see, I'm
looping length of L times
over the loop inside of there.
It's taking the
order one to test it.
So it's order n.
And if I were to actually count
it, there's the expression.
It's 1 plus 4n plus 1, which
is 4n plus 2, which by my rule
says I don't care about
the additive constant.
I only care about
the dominant term.
And I don't care about that
multiplicative constant.
It's order n.
An example of a template
you're going to see a lot.
Now, order n where n is
the length of the list
and I need to specify that.
That's the thing I'm after.
If you think about
it, I cheated.
Sorry-- I never cheat.
I'm tenure.
I never cheat.
I just mislead you badly.
Not a chance.
How do I know that accessing
an element of the list
takes constant time?
I made an assumption about that.
And this is a reasonable
thing to ask about-- both
what am I assuming about
the constant operations
and how do I know
that's actually true?
Well, it gives me a chance
to point out something
that Python does
very effectively.
Not all languages do.
But think about a list.
Suppose I've got a list
that's all integers.
I'm going to need
some amount of memory
to represent each integer.
So if a byte is 8 bits, I might
reserve 4 bytes or 32 bits
to cover any reasonable
sized integer.
When I represent a list, I
could simply have each of them
in turn.
So what do I need to know?
I'm going to allocate
out a particular length--
say 4 bytes, 32 bits, 32
sequential elements of memory
to represent each integer.
And then I just
need to know where's
the first part of
the list, what's
the address and memory of
the first part of the list.
And to get to the
i-th element, I take
that base plus 4 bytes times i.
And I can go straight
to this point
without having to
walk down the list.
That's nice.
OK?
It says, in fact, I can get
to any element of memory--
I'm sorry-- any element of
the list in constant time.
OK.
Now, what if the things I'm
representing aren't integers?
They're arbitrary
things and they take up
a big chunk of space.
Well, if the list
is heterogeneous,
we use a nice technique
called indirection.
And that simply says
we, again, have a list.
We know the address
of this point.
We know the address there for
the i-th element of this list.
But inside of here, we don't
store the actual value.
We store a pointer to
where it is in memory.
Just what these
things are indicating.
So they can be arbitrary size.
But again, I can get to any
element in constant time, which
is exactly what I want.
So that's great.
OK.
Now, suppose I tell you
that the list is sorted.
It's in increasing order.
I can be more clever
about my algorithm.
Because now, as I
loop through it,
I can say if it's the thing I'm
looking for, just return true.
If the element of the list
is bigger than the thing
I'm looking for, I'm done.
I don't need to look at
the rest of the list,
because I know it can't be there
because it's ordered or sorted.
I can just return false.
If I get all the way through
the loop, I can return false.
So I only have to look
until I get to a point
where the thing in
the list is bigger
than what I'm looking for.
It's the order of growth here.
Again, the average time
behavior will be faster.
But the order of
growth is I've got
to do order of
length of the list
to go through the loop,
order of one to do the test,
and in the worst
case, again, I still
have to go through
the entire list.
So the order of growth
here is the same.
It is, again, linear in
the length of the list,
even though the runtime
will be different depending
whether it's sorted or not.
I want you to hold
on to that idea,
because we're going to come
back to the sorted list
next week to see
that there actually
are much more efficient ways
to use the fact that a list is
sorted to do the search.
But both of these versions
same order growth, order n.
OK.
So lurching through a
list-- right, sorry--
searching through
a list in sequence
is linear because of that loop.
There are other things
that have a similar flavor.
And I'm going to
do these quickly
to get to the last example.
Imagine I give you a string of
characters that are all soon
to be composed of
decimal digits.
I just want to add them all up.
This is also linear,
because there's the loop.
I'm going to loop over the
characters in the string.
I'm going to cast
them into integers,
add them in, and
return the value.
This is linear in the
length of the input s.
Notice the pattern.
That loop-- that
in-iterative loop--
it's got that linear
behavior, because
inside of the loop
constant number of things
that I'm executing.
We already looked at fact iter.
Same idea.
There's the loop I'm going to
do that n times inside the loop
a constant amount of things.
So looping around it is order n.
There's the actual expression.
But again, the pattern
I want you to see here
is that this is order n.
OK.
Last example for today.
I know you're all secretly
looking at your watches.
Standard loops,
typically linear.
What about nested loops?
What about loops that
have loops inside of them?
How long do they take?
I want to show you a
couple of examples.
And mostly, I want to show
you how to reason about them.
Suppose I gave you two
lists composed of integers,
and I want to know
is the first list
a subset of the second list.
Codes in the handbook, by the
way, if you want to go run it.
But basically, the
simple idea would
be I'm going to loop over every
element in the first list.
And for each one
of those, I want
to say is it in the second list?
So I'll use the
same kind of trick.
I'll set up a flag
that's initially false.
And then I'm going to loop over
everything in the second list.
And if that thing is equal
to the thing I'm looking for,
I'll set match to true and
break out of the loop--
the inner loop.
If I get all the way
through the second list
and I haven't
found the thing I'm
looking for, when I break
out or come out of this loop,
matched in that case, will still
be false and all return false.
But if up here, I found
something that matched,
match would be true.
I break out of it.
It's not false.
Therefore, a return true.
I want you look at the code.
You should be able
to look at this
and realize what it's doing.
For each element
in the first list,
I walk through the second list
to say is that element there.
And if it is, I return true.
If that's true for all of the
elements in the first list,
I return true overall.
OK.
Order of growth.
Outer loop-- this loop
I'm going to execute
the length of L1 times.
Right?
I've got to walk
down that first list.
If I call that n, it's
going to take that n
times over the outer loop.
But what about n here?
All of the earlier examples,
we had a constant number
of operations
inside of the loop.
Here, we don't.
We've got another loop that's
looping over in principle
all the elements
of the second list.
So in each iteration is going
to execute the inner loop up
to length of L2 times, where
inside of this inner loop
there is a constant
number of operations.
Ah, nice.
That's the multiplicative
law of orders of growth.
It says if this is
order length L1.
And we're going to
do that then order
length of L2 times, the
order of growth is a product.
And the most common or
the worst case behavior
is going to be when the
lists are of the same length
and none of the elements
of L1 are in L2.
And in that case, we're
going to get something that's
order n squared
quadratic, where n
is the length of the list in
terms of number of operations.
I don't really
care about subsets.
I've got one more example.
We could similarly
do intersection.
If I wanted to say what is
the intersection of two lists?
What elements are on
both list 1 and list 2?
Same basic idea.
Here, I've got a
pair of nested loops.
I'm looping over
everything in L1.
For that, I'm looping
over everything in L2.
And if they are the same,
I'm going to put that
into a temporary variable.
Once I've done that, I
need to clean things up.
So I'm going to write
another loop that
sets up an internal variable
and then runs through everything
in the list I
accumulated, making sure
that it's not already there.
And as long as it isn't, I'm
going to put it in the result
and return it.
I did it quickly.
You can look through it.
You'll see it does
the right thing.
What I want it to see is
what's the order of growth.
I need to look at this piece.
Then I need to
look at that piece.
This piece-- well, it's order
length L1 to do the outer loop.
For each version of
e1, I've got to do
order of length L2 things
inside to accumulate them.
So that's quadratic.
What about the second loop?
Well, this one is a
little more subtle.
I'm only looping over temp,
which is at most going
to be length L1 long.
But I'm checking to see
is that element in a list?
And it depends on
the implementation.
But typically, that's
going to take up
to the length of
the list to do it.
I got to look to see
is it there or not.
And so that inner
loop if we assume
the lists are the
same size is also
going to take potentially
up to length L1 steps.
And so this is,
again, quadratic.
It's actually two
quadratics-- one
for the first nested loop,
one for the second one,
because there's an implicit
second loop right there.
But overall, it's quadratic.
So what you see
in general-- this
is a really dumb way
to compute n squared.
When you have nested
loops, typically, it's
going to be quadratic behavior.
And so what we've
done then is we've
started to build up examples.
We've now seen simple looping
mechanisms, simple iterative
mechanisms, nested loops.
They tend to naturally give
rise to linear and quadratic
complexity.
And next time, we're
going to start looking
at more interesting classes.
And we'll see you next time.